hey kids it's me Kevin Smith and we just
wrapped up the first ever uh smod Castle
Film Festival we had an awards ceremony
at spawn Castle Cinemas
um and it was absolutely lovely the
whole Fest was wonderful Ernie did a
phenomenal [ __ ] job turned into a
legit Film Festival man go figure so we
gave out a bunch of awards the awards
were chosen by the audience and stuff
they voted uh let's meet so the the
winners of the first ever
smod Castle Film Festival this is like
when they started American Idol and [ __ ]
and it was like Kelly whatever [ __ ] and
the other guy with the fro like what was
his name Justin and Kelly these are the
Justin and Kelly's of
smart Castle Film Festival tell them
your name I'm Rebecca DeMarco tell him
the project you brought marijuana
minutes and tell them what you're
holding an award for best actress in a
comedy wow uh how did it feel man when
they called your name pretty freaking
good right yeah you kidding me what was
it beautiful as you got up and you're
like I got a big ass speech and I'm
gonna get to the end and nobody bothered
to try to stop you we all stood back and
we're like take your moment yeah I
demand it you know you earned it after
having sex you earned it I appreciate it
um what was your overall impression of
the Spa Castle Film Festival I know it's
tainted by the fact that you won but
before you won what did you think before
I won everyone's been so kind I mean
throughout the whole process everyone
from the box office to the concession
stand everybody that works at this
Festival has been so kind and generous
with their time you know thank you for
shouting out the kids the kids who
worked the festival are literally kids
high school kids I love the kids I love
the children congratulations you're
you're a goddamn winner excellent job
minutes comes out on April 20th 2023 and
my director really wants to shake her
hand if you have time for it at any
moment did he win an award
I only shake hands of the award winners
of course not only will I shake his hand
I'll give him a big hug get in here
[ __ ] I had to
go plug one more time like she did plug
when has come out 420 2023 marijuana
minutes rent it stream it wherever it is
thank you excellent [ __ ] job congrats
congrats
look at these two double fisting [ __ ]
Awards and [ __ ] walking around like the
Coen Brothers just holding so much tin
what's your name Zach Morrison and
what'd you win here uh best editing or
for everything's fine a panic attack in
D Major and what's your name David
Seaman and what yeah yeah
and what'd you win for original music
everything's fine and panic attack in D
Major now what went through your mind
when your name was called when you win
an award what was the first thing that
happened I I I choke for a little bit
and I have an actual panic attack and
then I get up on stage and I realize
like it's actually okay
but it's the coolest feeling in the
world uh and it never it never gets old
yeah I mean I try to be ready to be
happy for whoever's gonna win and then
when it's me I go for that first like
and then uh I'm happy for me yeah
exactly like and that's okay to do that
right self-choice is what it's all about
for heaven's sakes uh what were your
impressions of the festival before you
won the awards obviously this taints it
a little bit what was your impression of
the festival pre-awards truly it's it's
been amazing and we're both from New
Jersey and to see a festival like this
and you being here supporting New Jersey
arts and and the film industry here it's
just so cool to see something like this
in our relative backyards you know
I'm trying not to freak out about being
here with you right now because it's
just like you know your commitment to
encouraging artists especially artists
from Jersey to make cool [ __ ] and put it
up in New Jersey because that's what
I've been trying to do and uh I know
that's what Zach does and uh so for you
to create a platform for people to do
that
I don't know I'm proud of you and in all
of you and it's it's very cool it means
the world man thank you uh that you
heard it from the mouths of the babes
themselves double winners right here
ladies and gentlemen excellent job kids
excellent job excellent meeting you man
thank you and thanks for coming and
bringing the film through Facebook all
right here we go what's your name
Captain uh Jeff Beals uh Jeff you're
holding tin what do you what'd you win
for uh Jeff Beals and Matt Beals winning
for the marshmallow Mystery Tour the
best comedy feature okay the very first
best comedy feature went to the
marshmallow Mystery Tour
um you are Jeremy risch and you are in
the marshmallow Mystery Tour in the
marshmallow Mystery Tour
um what was it like
what it feel like when it called your
name I don't I haven't won in a long
time explain winning to a loser it felt
like waking from a long long dream that
went for more than a decade this film
started to get written when my my son
was just born now he's 12. so it takes a
long time but you know it's kind of the
story of our lives and the story of a
lot of people's lives who grew up loving
all the stuff you were selling at quick
stop and then maybe ask themselves
where's this all coming from what's
going on what if Charlie really ran the
Chocolate Factory and then tries to tell
it as a real comedy so that's what we
tried to do it says what was it like for
you when when the film got called out
knowing you were up for an actor as well
but the movie itself won this was
predicated on the performance this
almost felt better in some ways because
it wasn't just about oh I'm a great
actor it's like oh wow we like really
did a thing as a team of people uh and
that it just kind of worn my heart and
because I love I I fell in love with
Jeff and Matt working on this movie and
we became Brothers doing this and it was
a huge family I mean talking hundreds of
people not working for anything but Love
of the Game and uh it was a and getting
arrested many times the amount of police
involvement here sorry you couldn't stop
us they locked up my brother at one
point but we got him out of jail and the
film got made
there's the story of indie film right
there kids not even jail we'll stop in
any filmmaker congratulations thank you
so much congratulations just say it's on
Amazon Prime now just released the
marshmallow Mystery Tour check it out
there and if you can tweet it out let
the world know we want them to see this
film thank you so much spread the word
the marshmallow Mystery Tour congrats
congrats boys such a pleasure excellent
see you tell them your name my name is
Aaron Brown Thomas tell them what you're
holding I'm holding a a moose or a cow a
movie yeah yeah what'd you win it for no
worries that's where moose came from no
oh moose is here yeah
um what what'd you win for this is uh
for uh acting in a comedy shorts called
called rekindled uh now what did it feel
like when they called your name
had not that many people
the other so it was a little bit like
real really amazing you guys must have
all voted for it felt very good felt
extraordinary I love making movies and
like I said like every time this happens
it's like hey maybe someone will let me
make another one so so damn true now
um I know the wind taints it but what
did you think of the festival before you
won how did Ernie do okay so here's the
thing I I curate for a living I have
been to probably like 100 film festivals
I can tell you what is really special
about this Festival there's no [ __ ]
ego here I love it I love how down to
earth this place is the moment we walked
in me and my friends felt it we said
this is going to grow into something
really special because it gives zero
[ __ ] about what it gives zero [ __ ]
about the things you shouldn't give any
[ __ ] about and you know everyone here
has been very unpretentious everyone's
been very welcoming of everyone everyone
knows how hard it is to make a movie
it's like pushing a rock uphill
constantly well also trying to like
sleep and eat and like not kill yourself
and so I felt that when I was here I
didn't feel it felt like everyone was
looking at each other in the eyes like
we are now and so I I I have only great
things to say about this Festival that
means that we'll congratulations so glad
you made a thing yes where can they see
it and how can they interact sure I
actually had four films at the festival
they're all on either you can find
thomas.com that and a couple other films
so erinbrownthomas.com Aaron Brown
Thomas underscore filmmaker on Instagram
and uh this one rekindled is on amaletto
on YouTube yeah you man excellent job
excellent job congrats uh tell them your
name hi I'm Heather Britton oh Scanlon
with victim number six uh what is this
this is the Golden Pig
what'd you win for I went for best actor
and a drama
and so what did it feel like when they
said your name I never win anything tell
me all right no one's buying that
because you are a big winner and you
inspire us all so thank you for that
um it felt amazing and I so I almost the
words that almost came out of my mouth
was every time I win I'm always
surprised and like I censored it in my
head before I spit it out because that
sounds like every time I went but
I I'm blessed with the film victim
number six has been doing well I feel
really thankful my director writer
director Nancy Mena and my producing
partner my co-star resveruso we had a
great team like I'm very very proud of
our project
so I
it's it's affirming every time any of us
gets a win and somehow I'm still
surprised every time we get a win so
it's truly amazing I am a Jersey girl
what part where from so I live in Colts
Neck uh oh my God they're your Monmouth
County girl from County girl the
Atlantic Highlands theater is a theater
I've been coming to for nearly 20 years
I'm so thankful you bought it and saved
it because Cinema should be seen in a
live Cinema with an audience and I'm so
thankful you're keeping that alive for
all of us filmmakers hey that means the
world B I'm glad we did it you got to
win [ __ ] where can they interact with
[ __ ] with the film so you can find me at
Heather oscanlin across all social media
victim number six is victim no six
hashtag victimno6 or victimno6.com
as man congratulations excellent job
it's going to be all about you tell them
your name oh uh I'm Keon hediati and
what are you holding right there I'm
holding the uh Best Director award first
officials mod Castle Film Festival boom
boom boom our very first Best Director
what's your name my name is Brandon
O'Dell uh what are you holding I'm
holding my cinematographers trophy for
best cinematography at Kevin Smith's
smart Castle Film Festival
his name is Emmanuel Andrade and he is
honestly when I first stepped on set I'm
the lead actor in the film I saw him and
I I was like oh [ __ ] this dude's working
way too [ __ ] hard
I gotta I gotta like step my [ __ ]
game up at the tone yeah what did it
feel like when they called that you what
I call that your name I mean it still
rather surreal just to be standing here
and talking with you we watch your films
forever we know who you are big time
hopefully you'll know who we are soon I
love you buddy do now [ __ ] you're our
first Best Director [ __ ] it it's more
of an honor than I can even explain like
it really is it just feels fantastic it
just feels fantastic to know that we can
keep making movies amen amen
um the uh it's been tainted because you
guys walked away with some tin but prior
to this what did you think how did Ernie
do with the Festival this year okay
Ernie
I'll give a little story the night
before the festival began I went to
Small Castle late at night because I got
my flight was late and I just wanted to
see what's going on and I go in there
and I see this or this guy just working
in there by himself and I go in and
Ernie lets me in and it's him and he
just starts making jokes with me and he
makes me feel comfortable makes me know
that like it's not about the competition
here it's just about like everybody
getting together and collaborating we're
going to be meeting a lot of people that
we're working with again absolutely so
Ernie's the [ __ ] man and he's the
only Festival director I've met that
taught me how to do the crane kick you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah so he's
fantastic what was the perspective like
as the guy who was the star of the film
watching all this being a part of it
man uh it's crazy uh because I quit my
job without having any money to like
actually bounce back and
maybe stay afloat no Back-up Plan yeah
and the fact that he had me in mind for
the lead role is absolutely nuts I mean
you're like one of my best friends it's
great uh thank you [ __ ] love you dude
uh the fact you had faith in me to do
that's crazy because never took acting
classes or anything I was working at UPS
for Christ's sakes not doing really much
but I didn't want to do that and you
knew it and uh just thank you man uh
can't believe it but this is [ __ ]
crazy I don't even know what I'm saying
what you're saying is beautiful man
you're acknowledging them for [ __ ]
lifting you up for giving you something
to be you saw something you believed in
you and [ __ ] look at you you're on your
way and you're more than on your [ __ ]
way well done man first best director of
the smog Castle Film Festival right
there uh what's your name Lloyd Pitts
what's your name Julian Maggio and what
are you holding right there I am holding
an award for the best horror at the
smodcast film festival 2022. now if I uh
understand Gregory and I can say for
these folks this is a creative
partnership that goes beyond the
creative partnership correct that is
correct we are a married couple
and uh we're both stun performers for TV
and film and that's how we met was on
set and uh training together we both
worked on Avengers end game Cobra Kai
Fear Street Trilogy and like 60 other
credits so we started out there and uh
got married and decided to start making
films
no better partner to make art with than
the partner
um what was it like what it feel like
rather when they called out the movie
it was unimaginable uh I still remember
the day that I was laying down on the
couch during lockdown and she walked in
and I've pitched my wife a hundred
different ideas and she's kind of rolled
her eyes at some of them but when I
pitched her the idea for gravedigger
that I'm holding this for she lit up and
was like what happens next and I didn't
have an answer yet I was like I just got
this idea and she's like well you have
to go put this on paper now so that that
moment was a year and a half ago and
it's still so fresh that this is
unimaginable that we're standing here
with you today holding this a year and a
half later you aggregated right to a
finished thing that's actually going to
a festival and winning excellent job
what was the creative process like how
do you break down between what who did
what
um so obviously I wrote the script I
passed it off to her and then while she
broke down locations costumes props and
everything on the back end I then
started creating concept art for the
characters and we'd go back and forth
and pick and choose because sometimes
you know we were working off of our own
budget and she'd say uh you can have a
or b you know what I mean uh so that was
it I was on the creative side and she
was complete back of the house now
something tells me that you were not
training your whole life to be back of
the house but you seemed like a front of
the house kind of person what was it
like being the facilitator
um it was honestly a nice balance for me
because I've been in front of camera for
so long and uh it was actually a really
exciting year for me because I actually
was one of the first ever to be Emmy
nominated in the sun performance
category and that was during the time we
were making Cobra Kai so I felt very
fulfilled creatively performing in front
of camera so to finally get to be behind
camera and facilitate and I'm very
analytical so it's really exciting to be
doing all that and be like holy [ __ ] I'm
making a [ __ ] film and I'm figuring
it out we're getting you know we had a
40 to 50 person crew and we were just
working it out every step of the way so
we are very compatible not just in
marriage but in creators together so
it's great being performers that now
know how to harness and tell your own
stories means the sky is the limit you
don't need anybody's permission or help
ever again how awesome man
um I know this evening is Tainted
because you guys won something but prior
to that what was your impression of the
film festival did Ernie do a good job oh
absolutely no this this was Immaculate
your staff at the uh at the cinema
itself was very inviting uh they had
also offered really great feedback
Because by the time we got here everyone
had already seen our film which we were
unprepared for
so uh it's almost like while we were on
our way we forgot anyone was going to
watch it besides us we we you know we
were hoping that people outside of our
friends and family were going to see
this and for us to walk through the
front doors and uh Ernie was the first
person to be like I loved your film I
was like oh my God people have watched
it okay
it was amazing
um how about you
um it was awesome so uh my parents
actually were very much in the process
my father was executive producer and one
of the actors in our film awesome so I'm
all about family and our you know we
have a very close-knit group of friends
who do everything with us so I think
everything that small Castle was really
embraced that and it was so cool to meet
so many people that are so close to you
that you've been creating with since day
one because that's what we do too so it
felt like we were already home and it
was a really fun really fun film
festival damn beautiful man thank you
for that kids congratulations
thank you means damn world that you can
let me tell you a quick story I started
to tell you this on stage but seven
years ago you were in Atlanta and I met
you outside of the venue and I told you
yeah I'm trying to get out of stunts I
really want to be a director you looked
at me and I say this with love like I
was stupid and you're like well go
[ __ ] direct man and you I was like oh
I don't have a quit I started coming up
with excuses that now I know are
[ __ ] but you were like pull out your
[ __ ] phone and make a movie so it was
so serendipitous to come and see you
here at this festival and say hey I
listened you did that means the [ __ ]
world man thank you so thank you so much
for encouraging people show them the
photo of you guys I have a photo from
[ __ ]
yeah oh my God look at how young you
look and look how heavy I look
so dope man well done God damn God that
you encouraged the the film Community to
do what we're doing because taking it
from paper to screen is uh you know
courage wise the hardest thing you can
possibly do
yeah you did it you guys been awarded
for it congratulations congratulations
making art together right here what's
your name Kevin Bryce what's your name
Captain Rob uh what are you holding in
your hand this is a golden movie for uh
best comedy short and the name of that
comedy short that won Jimmy
uh these are the cats who won for Jimmy
man and they obviously called each other
up to say what are you gonna wear what
was it like when you heard Jimmy
announced tonight it was pretty wild
because it's about a
big old dong uh and so we just thought
how [ __ ] silly man how [ __ ] silly
a film about big dick winning in a Kevin
Smith Film Festival is very on brand
very on brand how'd you feel when most
when we said Jimmy
felt really good felt a little hard uh I
mean you know the uh the statue felt a
little hard it was great it was great
yeah now the evening's been tainted for
you gentlemen because you do walk away
with an award but prior to winning the
award what was your impression of
smodcast Castle Film Festival oh my God
man we loved it we're we're from about
an hour north of here where where we're
from Suffern New York and then we moved
to Mahwah Jersey we moved out to LA uh
and this I mean this has been a dream
honestly to come here with you is
it literally is everything honestly man
there's everything to us that [ __ ]
means the world
it's me too um we're gonna do it again
next year and we'll do it again after
that you guys are gonna come back [ __ ]
yeah we got a movie ready to rock and we
just finished our second feature
you do we do and what is the split
between you guys what's the breakdown of
the work uh the work wise
I'm the guy who sits there at the
computer and he's the guy who
he's like the secretary
yeah uh yeah it's honestly it's even
we're both in the movies we're both
directing the movies we edit we write we
produce we raise the money it's it's
just a two-man show literally it's
[ __ ] Cohen Brothers right here kids
pulling it together congratulations
proud of you boys congratulations
winners tell them your name my name is
Ron tomato and what are you holding Ron
I am holding the infamous movie cow here
and what'd you win for I won best
documentary short for apartment 38.
um what did it feel like when uh your
name was said by the great Bob Hawk
I'm speechless I was speechless well
first of all your speech right before it
albeit long as [ __ ] was long
um it was very powerful and uh very
special and and you had a lot of emotion
in that too in that speech and I saw
that and I felt that very powerful intro
and to have Bob intro documentary and to
have your the person who started you in
the business dude I mean I don't even
know what to say about that was we
grabbed it I forgot to say it when I was
introduced about the whole reason he did
documentaries because he worked on the
times of Harvey Milk which won an
Academy Award like years and years ago
so we were like well Bob is the
documentary guy right
um what the uh obviously the evening's
been tainted because you won an award
yes but prior to that what was your
impression of the film festival
it was awesome
um it was I've been to many films
actually I run my own Film Festival back
in Albuquerque the 48-hour film project
and um the way this Festival was ran
first of all I loved the um
the seminars that you had I went to the
second one that you had this afternoon
they were fun man it was I and you hit
the nail on the head with the questions
that were being asked in the audience
those are the seminars I want to go to
thoughtful questions with responses that
is going to help filmmakers pursue their
careers
um so with that and also not only
watching the films but the networking
networking as you know it's important in
this industry and with all these awesome
filmmakers here with everybody just
putting in their heart and soul into
these films and then talking to them
afterwards oh my God it was such a great
experience I feel like I know so much
more about film just after this weekend
the um you know the idea of jumping in
the waters we were unfamiliar with in
terms of like pulling off a whole
festival
the fear of it was outweighed by this
moment the notion that like somebody
would walk away with somebody and walk
away with a prize walk away with some
sense of like hey man we didn't do it
for nothing people have seen it and
whatnot where can they [ __ ] with the
flick I'm sorry what was that where can
they [ __ ] with the flick where can they
find the flick ah yes so my current
flick right now is not up however I'm
planning to do a uh YouTube stream of it
um date yet to be announced but that
YouTube stream will be on uh green cat
green couch media at some point in the
near future
and also there's a website for
supplemental material apt-38movie.com
beautiful pivot up from kids well done
and I know you don't remember but I met
you many many many many many many many
many many many many many years ago and
another photo oh another photo I'm not
the first uh but
oh my God where where are we okay so
we're in Red Bank in 2006 you hosted um
an evening with Kevin Smith at The Count
Basie Theater and then afterwards at the
secret stash you said everybody come out
I'll sign autographs take pictures
whatever
um and the line was out the door this
was the longest q and I ever did the
night of the seven hour q a so that was
um that was that night and the line was
wrapped all the way around the block Red
Bank police had to be called in to
monitor the line so you created quite a
commotion that night but it was such a
memorable night it was such a memorable
night
look at these two Young Bucks
one of them uh passed a film the other
future man
my God that's tremendous and look at
this we're standing together again let's
take a selfie and recreate this oh yeah
let's do it
oh we're there yep they're over there
[Music]
excellent job excellent thank you Kevin
and thank you to you and to Ernie for
putting this together I mean does I know
it was all Ernie but with you being the
face of it it's given a lot of people
um hope that they can actually get their
films out and
just that Spirit you've got that Spirit
here so thank you so much thank you
means a goddamn world what's your name
Captain tell me your name Pierre guilla
tell them your name Captain Samuel uh
you're both uh standing up here because
we got some tin tell me what happened uh
we won best documentary feature for a
book of hearth
um what did it feel like when book of
Hearts was called
I did not believe it because I have sat
in that chair and not been called many
times so I just gave this guy a squeeze
and uh yeah I felt like I was kind of
invisible walking up there as well like
it was a surreal moment
wow what about you what did it feel like
when they said it it's incredible uh but
I I owe a lot to him because I actually
stole his speech going up you know I we
were driving here and I said uh what are
you gonna say if we win man like we
didn't prepare anything and he said well
what are you gonna say so I said some
[ __ ] and then he's like well this is
what I'm gonna say and I said all right
and then subconsciously I just said
exactly what he [ __ ] said man
totally betrayed me
yeah yeah but um it's been a real
pleasure man it's been a real pleasure
to be here you had my favorite sentiment
of the night though where you got up at
the when they won and he was like look
I've been to a lot of things of these
Awards things I hate them but he was
like this was okay well see this is this
this is what happens when someone steals
your lines like you have to come on you
have to rip yeah yeah it was beautiful I
loved it really captured the moment man
that's tremendous what thanks for being
in our film by the way I ran up on you
February 2020 and you gave the best
interviews the best two minutes ever it
was it was incredible that's that's all
Kevin Smith ever gives anybody two
minutes and not even the best for
heaven's sakes two minutes while the
oral is pretty damn good what uh I know
it's tainted because you won 10. what
what was your impression of the film
festival up to that moment before you
won just super warm I mean it's all
about film festivals are all about the
community and filmmaking and that's what
we've experienced up until now for sure
it's been great even events like these
the screenings everyone's been nice the
staff
Ernie as much as everyone talks [ __ ]
about him he's actually a great guy
really great guy what was your
impression I'm impressed I'm impressed
that it has such a Vibe for the first
year like it has an identity like I feel
like I'm walking into a place that's
lived already for a while so that's
really sweet you were the king of the
compliment man [ __ ] that's beautiful
you did very well don't sell yourself
short look at these [ __ ] winners
right here look at these [ __ ] winners
faces look at these faces study their
[ __ ] faces that's the face of winners
right there well done uh okay what's
your name I'm Mark Brown Mark AC Brown
because of IMDb uh what's your name Tom
Sawyer best actor what's your name I'm
Serena Brown best Ensemble and what's
your name Victoria Johnston ditto now
what's the name of the project that you
guys have not one not two but three the
third one's not present awards for uh
dead on the vine
tell them what it is
um it's a Fitch film it's a thriller
it's um
Darkly humorous things Santa Vineyards
do I do need to say more no that's
beautiful uh what was it like when we
said
that on the vine
um which time there's three
um
it gave me
incredible happiness and it did lots of
uh
lovely lovely feelies
yeah blew my mind blew my mind it's
beautiful man there was a lot of love
for you in that room yeah I felt like it
felt good it felt good it was uh
it was a nervous thing this is our first
Festival
is that right yes our world premiere and
and then we wanted it to be here I I I
asked my my producer who is much more
successful than I am
eventually entering into other stuff and
doing things and she's I was like can I
can I do swad castle please because
and uh she was like yeah okay
one of them
don't embarrass him I've got I've got
loads of Heroes you're just I'm one of
many you're in top ten
um
and so she's like yeah fine fine enter
that one and uh so we did and we got in
and then uh boom here we are winning
cool [ __ ] and um so it's been a an
exceptional experience
Now you won
best actor and literally got up and gave
the fun speech man the best speech of
the night the best accepted speech tell
them what you said so best actor
everyone else who wants to be an actor
should stop because we found the best
actor
we did it right here in New Jersey go
figure what was it like when they said
your name how'd it feel I mean it was
obvious
who else is going to win but me right
right you knew I did everyone knew
that's true I was nominated in that
category and you know I'm I'm a bit
peeved that you yes thank you I may well
I mean I obviously contributed as did
Victoria to his bestness
and you know you're welcome for that
thank you but yeah you deserved it bro
you guys got in on ensemble
what was it like when we call that
Ensemble for you guys
best thing ever Mark Brown's got a trait
of uh winning vest Ensemble so it's all
kudos to him
[Applause]
I like fighting lots of characters who
talk all at the same time you know
and the awards have worked out
accordingly it's just nice
[Music]
um
you know two people in the room
I did it I did it my first film second
film I'll try four people in the room
and uh that's it seems to have been okay
for me
um what uh I know it's tainted because
you walked away with three Awards what
was your impression though of the
festival prior to winning did uh Ernie
do a good job oh my God I I've loved it
Ernie
this Traders really well even before we
got to the festival when we were
heading trying to hear a deadline of of
getting the film finished
and Ernie was very um to say very
respectful of our inability to do that
and um so he gave us a couple a couple
of extensions
and uh yeah it's welcomed us and has
been an absolute uh gent since since we
arrived so more than happy and with
those accents it's clear that you kids
came from South Jersey
yes we've lived in Asbury Park
um since uh since since birth dude well
tell them where you came from
um well I think we all came from London
right
um
none of us are actually from London I
think except for Tom I think you know
you're not even from London basically
London yeah
but yeah ultimately sort of
if we named the other places I'm not
sure the Americans wouldn't understand
where we're talking about anyway but
yeah I'm the north I'm a northern
England man you're a northern England
woman so Scottish and uh
Kent
Kent and David Whitney who is not here
who is a very loud man who's gonna be
very upset by not being here
um he's also from London
but he was the other guy dies in The
Ensemble I can't believe you guys made
the trip like people submitted from
around the world but not everyone made
the trip I'm so glad you guys did it
would have been weird to give three
Awards to nobody
no brainer for me to come to me
it's my first feature
and I was like I have to come it's gonna
be like this every time I'm sure
I'm so pleased I did because and I'm not
saying this just because you're here in
all your wonderful Red Jacket nurse
but it it was truly inspirational and I
brought my daughter and she was inspired
by the whole idea of creating and making
mistakes but picking yourself back up
and just doing it feeling the fear and
doing it anywhere and I think that's
what this this Festival epitomizes
actually and I just it was very
inspirational
so she said you're not bad for a bunch
of actors she expected you to be
obnoxious highest review you could get
from a blood relative
you finally made it we were looking for
you tell them your name David David
Whitney please tell me what you did with
the film David uh uh I'm one of the
actors one of The Ensemble yes where is
The Ensemble award did you leave it
elsewhere do you leave it in a cab
somewhere I think I I sowed it that's it
all right this is the one which one are
we missing
what was it like when we called out uh
The Ensemble do you feel seen yeah I do
man I mean it's yeah I mean they're a
great team and I I love loved doing it
and it's one of the I I I'm mainly I'm
in my living is a stand-up and the main
the main difference for me is being part
of the team rather because there's a
stand-up you're just a gun for hire you
go out there and you can you can rip a
gig and then you go back to your action
on your [ __ ] Todd uh and being part
of a team is so much more Rich enriching
and much more fulfilling so to win The
Ensemble it for me is the best best
thing that could happen amazing
beautifully put man give it up for the
kids the winners three Awards two
presidents
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old up Kevin
Smith
[Music]